Sus peligrosos síntomas fueron controlados
y María tuvo una niña sana.
Y, antes de darle el alta del hospital,
su médico la asesoró nuevamente sobre los signos y síntomas de la preeclampsia,
la importancia de hacerse controlar la presión,
especialmente en la primera semana de postparto,
y la educó sobre la salud después del parto y sobre qué debía esperar.
Durante las siguientes semanas y meses,
María tuvo visitas de seguimiento con su pediatra
para que controlara la salud de su niña.
Pero, igualmente importante,
tuvo visitas continuas con su ginecólogo
para controlar su salud, su presión sanguínea
y sus precauciones y preocupaciones como madre primeriza.
Este es el aspecto de una atención de calidad en el espectro de atención
y así debería ser.
Si cada embarazada de cada comunidad
recibiera este tipo de atención de calidad
y diera a luz en sitios que utilicen prácticas de atención estándares,
nuestras tasas de mortalidad y morbilidad maternas extremas se desplomarían.
Nuestro posicionamiento en el mundo ya no sería una vergüenza.
Pero la verdad es que hemos tenido décadas de altos índices, inaceptables,
de muerte materna y complicaciones potencialmente mortales durante el parto
y décadas de consecuencias devastadoras para las mamás, los bebés y las familias,
y no hemos hecho nada.
La atención reciente de los medios al mal desempeño con la mortalidad materna
ayudó para que la gente comprendiera
que la atención materna de calidad está a nuestro alcance.
La cuestión es:
¿Estamos listos como sociedad a valorar a las embarazadas de cada comunidad?
Por mi parte, hago todo lo que puedo para asegurarnos de que cuando lo hacemos,
tengamos las herramientas y la base empírica listas
para avanzar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)